Hey guys, Matt here for Science or Fiction
and today I’ll tell you how I plan to live
forever with antioxidants.
I just bought a TON groceries. I've got some blueberries here, we have some dark chocolate.
This is gonna be awesome, right? Oh!
Can antioxidants really lead to a longer,
healthier life?
Maybe you’ve heard that certain berries
or nuts are good for you because of the antioxidants.
And all that dark chocolate that you like to eat around the holidays, you know, like Christmas,
Valentine’s Day, Passover, Easter, Arbor
Day.
Everyone eats chocolate on Arbor Day, right?
Well, those antioxidants are going to help
you live longer, too.
Or is it the opposite?
I mean, these headlines makes it seem like
you should lock that chocolate up and throw
your acai bowl in the trash.
So which is it?
Will antioxidants help you live longer, or
stop you from living all together?
Well, like a 2006 Facebook relationship status,
it’s complicated.
First you should know there’s a thing called
“free radicals” which is not only an excellent
band name, but they are also the natural by-products
of chemical processes like those that occur
when our bodies turn food into energy .
Free radicals steal electrons from our lipids,
nucleic acids, and proteins which slowly damages
our genetic material and contributes to the
aging process.
And that’s where antioxidants come in.
Antioxidants intervene by providing extra
electrons to free radicals so they stop stealing
them from other places in our bodies.
So it would seem eating a bunch of antioxidant-rich
foods like blueberries should then slow the
aging process, right?
Well living longer isn’t as simple as just
ridding your body of free radicals.
One study indicated that free radicals may
be a product rather than a cause of aging,
and in some circumstances, free radicals may
actually increase the longevity of cells.
Now, research has shown that people who eat
more fruits and vegetables, which happen to
be high in antioxidants, have a lower risk
of disease.
But there’s no proof that it’s the antioxidants
in the food that’s causing this.
There’s also little evidence that taking
supplements full of antioxidants like vitamin
C, or beta-carotene offer any significant
effect on heart disease, cancer, or other
chronic conditions, although the jury is still out on Vitamin E.
You’re Ok for now Vitamin E, but I’ve
got my eye on you.
So antioxidants may not have all the health benefits that the media and nutrition companies claim.
But could antioxidants actually be bad for
you?
When it comes to antioxidant supplements,
maybe.
A study showed that one source of antioxidants,
beta-carotene, may increase the chances of
developing lung cancer in men who are heavy smokers.
Rates of skin cancer were shown to be higher
in women who took a combination of vitamin
C, vitamin E, beta-carotene, selenium, and
zinc.
And studies have shown that rather than increasing
lifespans generally, antioxidant supplements
may be associated with a shorter lifespans.
In the end, antioxidant supplements are a
mixed bag that you might want to be careful with.
But antioxidant heavy foods, like dark chocolate
and blueberries, really, don’t have enough
antioxidants to probably do much of anything.
So keep on eating those, but only because
they’re delicious, not because they’ll
extend your life.
Which reminds me, does anybody want any blueberries?
How about some dark chocolate?
I bought way too much.
I thought I was going to live forever. No?
So antioxidants might not be that good for you, but vitamins are definitely good for
you, right?
...Right?
Find out in this video here, don’t forget
to subscribe,
and keep coming back to Seeker for more videos.